Your wife stops sleeping with you after you guys had children
because she can see the similarities between your fucking behavior.
And it's a real turn off to fuck a man that reminds you of a toddler.
It's just not sexy
when I have to talk you down from your emotional tantrums
the same fucking way I have to with our children.
You're damn right.
There's gonna be a fucking Sahara Desert for you tonight
after the fucking delicious dinner that I made for you.
Yeah, I'm gonna pour all my energy into everything,
even managing your own fucking feelings.
And then you think I'm going to fuck you?
No, sir. No.
That's why your dick is in your hand night after night after night.
And that's why soon you'll be divorced.
Men are so fucking confused when the dead bedroom happens.
When they don't realise
that shit has been in the making since the beginning.
It's not because of your wife had children.
It's because your wife can see the similarities
in your behavior to the children.
Maybe she doesn't know how to put words to that,
but I guarantee you
a little light bulb went off right now if she didn't.